italy was one of the worst affected
nations in the kovan 19 pandemic
but the country is slowly reopening as
part of this
italian national and local authorities
have implemented extensive anti-body
testing campaigns
this is to determine how many people
have developed immunity to copen19
it's also opened up a new market for
antibody test manufacturers
massimiliano mojetti is the ceo of dies
sidinosti case
a firm of about 200 employees dies is
providing the regional government in
tuscany
with 500 000 antibody tests and is
producing 1.2 million tests a month
the firm makes tests that detect three
kinds of antibodies
the immune system develops to fight off
a disease unlike most of the other tests
on the market
which currently only measure two types
of antibodies for a company that has the
size of my company
remaining competitive in a market that
is very capital intensive there is only
one key
and it is innovation so you need to be
very innovative in order to compete
with those who can put the muscles on
the table if you understand what i mean
multinational firms are now making a
push to get their cut of the italian
market
looking to use the country as a
springboard to offer their tests in
other countries as demand for the tests
increases
american giant abbott labs has been
particularly prominent
providing antibody tests to the italian
national government
and regional authorities in sicily and
piedmont
but in the same way confusion and
competition built up between american
governors bidding for ventilators
regional italian governors are now
finding themselves in a similar
situation
with antibody tests with little guidance
from the italian national government
on how to navigate this new market for
example
in the central region of market with a
population of about 1.5 million people
governor luka charlie says there's been
a slow response from the national
government and a lack of clarity on
antibody testing
as a result his region went ahead with
antibody testing of healthcare workers
at major hospitals
dr antonio giordano who is the founder
and director of the savaro institute for
cancer research and molecular medicine
at temple university in philadelphia
says that as the antibody testing market
opens up in the united states
authorities can learn from italy where
the government should have been more
active early on in setting rules and
expectations
on the market point of view government
should
be very strong in dictating the rules
that the big pharma or the biotech
interests are aggressively pursuing
because
that's what is happening we you open up
the newspaper you see
everyone develop a test everyone
developed a vaccine and
everyone starts a clinical trial but you
don't know worldwide which one is
the true one if you don't have a strong
a rigorous
uh monitoring of the of the process
another takeaway for americans according
to the ceo massimiliano bogetti
is increased cooperation between the
government the scientific community
and manufacturers companies do play
a very important role in maintaining a
population
in an ethnic status so we need to
increase
the cooperation between scientific
community
and industry to make sure that there is
not
a lack of this type of testing
or of the medical device equipment
that are essential when you are fighting
for with an epidemic
you need to count on a domestic
production to make sure that once and if
a new epidemic appears you need
for sure to fight this epidemic as
an international community but to some
extent you need also to count on some
national production
you